hello grammarians hello a man hello
uh today we're going to be talking about
four sets of frequently confused words
and the one that i want to begin with is
advice
and advise
how do we keep these two words straight
well first of all advice
with a c
is a noun and advise with an s
is a verb
and these are really easy to screw up
because they look very similar and you'd
think
that they have approximately the same
sound but the c
in advice actually ends up having a sur
sound an s and the s in advise
ends up having a z sound a z sound
so let's use these both in a sentence
bertram gives terrible advice
mopewa advised us not to surf on a full
stomach
so the word advice the noun contains
another noun the the word vice which is
kind of like a it's a type of clamp
um usually
tightened by means
of um like a metal screw
and you turn it with a handle
and uh in in my context in my experience
i've used it in woodworking projects to
keep pieces of wood still so you want to
clamp something
while it's being glued together you've
got two pieces of wood let's say this
little piece of redwood
and this little piece of blue wood
you want to glue them together
hold them still with a vice so if you
remember that a vice is a noun
you can remember that advice is a noun
and when you advise someone yes you are
giving them advice
but this is the verb form
so now we have two other words that
sound the same but are very different we
have allowed and allowed now they're
both adjectives but they have different
spellings and different meanings so
let's start with the first allowed which
is spelled a-l-o-u-d
note that it has the word loud in it
which can help us remember that this
word talks about something being spoken
loudly
so let's use that in a sentence
ginny
muttered aloud
so when we say allowed a-l-o-u-d
we mean it's audible it can be heard
contains that word aloud
cool what's this next one aloud with two
elves and a good way to remember this is
to think about the word legal which has
two l's if something is legal
it is also allowed or permissible
so let's think of an example
oliver allowed no peppers in his soup
very allergic he's very allergic yes
similarly you might be allowed to drive
at 60 miles per hour because it is legal
to drive at that speed
sweet
let's move on to our next set
so over here we have break
and
break so these are both nouns and verbs
right to break something is to you know
crack it in half
or to split
or just to ruin or destroy something
but it also
refers to the results of a crack or a
split like you could say the break in a
vase
and whereas break also a noun and a verb
refers to slowing stuff down so
to slow down or the mechanism that does
the slowing so we we have here both
a verb form and we have here the verb
form and the noun form
so how do you remember the difference
between them
let's let's let's take it from the
decision point so i'm writing a sentence
and i'm trying to figure out
which one i want to use so let's just
kind of imagine we've got this
onward
brock here
now if i want to use
the the break and destroy sense in order
to do that i just have to
break the word in half and put and put
that e
right in the middle
i broke the word in half i put the the e
right in the center and that means that
i've cracked the word but let's say um
i've got
brac over here i want to slow down it's
forward momentum i'm going to put that e
right at the end it looks sort of like a
spring we want to halt its momentum by
putting that e at the end so let's put
these into a sentence okay so
jesse breaks a vase and how do we
remember to say breaks with eak well we
put the e in the middle we break the
word in half we put the e in the middle
let's do the other one
paulo slammed on the brakes and how do
we remember we want to have the e at the
end well the e is trying to slow paulo
down
we're trying to halt that momentum by
putting that spring looking e at the end
of the word
this one's one of my favorites um it's
the difference between bear b-e-a-r and
bear b-a-r-e
now the word bear e-a-r can be either a
verb
or a noun
and when it's a when it's a noun it's
this critter
but when it's a verb it means
to carry
and b-a-r-e is an adjective
meaning naked or empty
and when i say bear as a verb i mean
that in the sense of bearing a burden if
you've heard that expression or if
you've ever heard somebody say i can't
bear it
that literally means i can't carry it
but metaphorically it means i can't
withstand it and bear is something more
like the cupboards were bare
meaning empty
you know
open up the cupboard a fly comes out
something like that so how do we keep
these two words separate
well all you have to remember is this
simple mnemonic
e before a
take it away
a before e
everyone can see that you are naked or
that your cupboard is empty so those are
just a couple of mnemonic devices just
memory aids
that will ideally assist you in keeping
these sets of words straight you can
learn anything david out e-man out